wait let's play let's play one game
rated
three thousand just
let's play julie 86
julian baltog from moldava moldova sorry
let's play rate player rated 3000 let's
have a serious game
so i'll play bishop b5
uh let's play what i recommend in the
course
so c3 with the id of d4
yeah thank you chef nip rookie one
castle v4 d5
e5 knight e4
take stakes
wesley is quite the humble guy for such
a great player
yeah thank you nashville and jess
um yeah well to me chess is uh
just a job you know well to anyone
really
but uh chess to me is just a career
so just like many other people had great
careers
so i don't really think you should brag
about your job
if you're good at it
that's not that's just not the way how
things are done in in the us
that's all good i see three
chestnuts yeah chestnut you were playing
very fast
too fast thank you
love jeff bishop f5
i think i can just take play knight d2
so black's bishop on g7 is quite passive
and bishop on e3 protects everything so
the most important factor in this
position is
the central pawns on d4 and on e5
so the dark squares on the center are
the most important thing here now my
knight comes to c5
and yeah i must say that was uh
that was a pretty exciting game with uh
with chestnut
i mean it was a pretty fun game and if
he didn't play rook takes a seven in the
end
things could have gotten messy
uh yeah white is better here because
blockade on the dark squares
knight c5
and uh black cannot kick away my knight
on c5 okay a4 is a good move
but white should still be better
no rating shop 1300 to 3 000.
yeah it's only blitz so it's okay
i mean it's quite easy to adjust on
blitz
reading shop okay
i actually have to play a move which i
don't want to play
but i'll play bishop b4 to protect my
knight on c5
yeah actually julix's time is very poor
right now so he's gonna lose some time
because we're not playing with
increments
so uh he better speed up
uh i mean his position is not bad
but his time is very low
so we should just start playing fast
flag 30 seconds
29 seconds
master the tempo
yeah i play against bots all day that's
why i play like a boat
yeah that's always the goal in chess you
need to master the tempo
and if you master the tempo then you can
become as good as the bot
rook f5
okay julie 86 good game uh
didn't really have any time on the end
um